first let me give an update on the
latest data that we have on coronavirus
and I can report that through the
government's ongoing monitoring and
testing program but as of today we there
have now been one million three hundred
eighty three thousand eight hundred and
forty two tests for coronavirus across
the UK including eighty four thousand
eight hundred and six tests yesterday we
know that one hundred ninety four
thousand nine hundred and ninety people
have tested positive and that's an
increase of four thousand four hundred
and six cases since yesterday and of
those who have tested positive twenty
nine thousand four hundred and twenty
seven have very sadly died and our
hearts go out to everyone who has lost a
loved one
throughout the coronavirus challenge we
continue to see evidence of a flattening
of the peak of this virus but as the
figures that I've just read out show
it's not over yet so in the coming days
saij will update ministers with their
latest scientific advice and as ever we
will make sure that we are continue we
continue to be guided by their advice as
we take the decisions on next steps in
fighting this virus alongside the advice
that we get from sage our five tests
remain absolutely key first we must
continue to boost NHS capacity so that
the NHS cannot be overwhelmed second we
need to see a sustained and consistent
fall in the number of deaths thirdly we
must see further reductions in the rate
of infection to manageable levels across
all different settings and areas fourth
we must be confident that the NHS will
be able to cope with future demands
including as a result of any changes
that we make to existing measures or
indeed any new measures that we might
wish to take and fifth and above all we
need to be confident that any
adjustments to the current measures
won't risk a second peak of infections
that could then overwhelm the NHS later
on this week the PM will update the
country on the measures and the
decisions that we will need to take to
protect the NHS to safeguard the economy
and to avoid the risk
of a second peak that will be damaging
both for public health but also for jobs
and the wider economy and as we consider
the decisions that we will take next to
protect life but also to protect our way
of life it's now clear that the second
phase will be different we will need to
adjust to a new normal where we as a
society adapt to safe new ways to work
to travel to interact and to go about
our daily lives we've never experienced
anything like this first stage of covert
19 in terms of the scale of the lives
lost but also the lockdown that it is
required and as we go forward we want to
make sure that the next phase is more
comfortable is more sustainable and
prevents lasting damage to jobs and
livelihoods but we need to be under no
illusions the next stage won't be easy
and if we're going to protect life and
preserve our way of life as I just said
we must continue to be guided by the
scientific advice we receive and make
sure the next steps that we take are
sure-footed and sustainable now before I
hand over to Angela to run through the
data slides I want to provide an update
on one further feature that coronavirus
as a challenge has thrown up for this
country and indeed for the whole world
whilst the vast majority of people and
countries have come together and rallied
to this international mission to defeat
coronavirus there will always be some
who seek to exploit a crisis for their
own criminal and hostile ends we know
that cyber criminals and other malicious
groups are targeting individuals
businesses and other organizations by
deploying kovat 19 related scams and
phishing emails and that includes groups
that in the cyber security world are
known as advanced persistent threat
groups sophisticated networks of hackers
who try to breach computer systems and
we have clear evidence now that these
criminal gangs are actively targeting
national and international organizations
responding to the covert 19 pandemic
which I have to say makes them
particularly dangerous and venal at this
time so we're working with the targets
of those attacks with the potential
targets and with others to make sure
that they're aware of the cyber threat
and that they can take the steps
necessary to protect themselves or at
the very least mitigate the harm that
could be wrought against them so with
that in mind today the UK's national
cybersecurity center and the u.s. cyber
security and infrastructure security
agency have published a joint warning
about these groups and we've offered
some advice on the cyber criminals and
other actors who are seeking to exploit
Kovach 19 through malicious cyber
activity our teams have identified
campaigns targeting healthcare bodies
pharmaceutical companies research
organizations and also various different
arms of local government now there are
various objectives and motivations that
lie behind these attacks from fraud on
the one hand to espionage but they tend
to be designed to steal bulk personal
data intellectual property and wider
information that supports those aims and
they're often linked with other state
actors and we expect this kind of
predatory criminal behavior to continue
into evolved over the coming weeks and
months ahead and we're taking a range of
measures to tackle that threat so as
we've done today we'll share advice on
the nature of those threats to enable
businesses citizens and our
international partners to better defend
themselves against the full range of
cyber attack from hostile States to
criminal gangs preventive action is
often the very best way to deny attack
as the opportunities that they're
looking for the national cybersecurity
sent off as a range of practical advice
to safeguard against cyber attacks from
things like using the use of online
passwords to guidance on what are the
trusted sources of online information
related to covert 19 like the gun case
i'ts or public health England
now as well as providing practical
advice the UK will continue to counter
those who conduct cyber attacks and
we're working very closely with our
international partners to respond to the
threats but also to deter their gangs
and the arms of state who lie behind
them we're absolutely determined to
defeat coronavirus and also to defeat
those trying to exploit the situation
for their own nefarious ends and with
that I'll pass over to Professor McLane
to give us the latest update on the data
[ __ ] let the first light please so the
first slide reminds us what are the five
tests for adjusting lockdown and number
one is that we should always ensure that
the NHS has enough capacity that is able
to provide critical care and specialist
treatment right across the UK the second
is that we should see a sustained and
consistent fall in daily deaths from
coronavirus and the third is that there
must be reliable data to show that the
rate of infection is decreasing to
manageable levels right across the board
fourth is that operational challenges
including testing and PPE must be in
hand with supply able to meet future
demand and fifth is that we should be
confident that any adjustments that are
made to current measures will not risk a
second peak of infections that
overwhelms the NHS if I could have the
next slide please so this is a slide
about transport use and how it's changed
in Great Britain since the let's look
since February so those percentages are
relative to normal use during February
and the vertical dotted line is the date
when lockdown started and what you see
is that for public transport there has
been a very marked and very persistent
fall through that's but fought for bus
for kube for national rail and also in
grey further back for buses in London
for motor vehicle so that's the top dark
blue line what you see is a pattern that
looks a bit like commuting because it's
low every weekend and we do worry about
that creeping up I think all of us
remember that what we've done together
which is to stay home has worked to
protect the NHS and save lives and as
one of the people who looks at this data
and thinks about how it fits in to how
we think about the future it does
trouble me that the dark blue line is
creeping up again next slide please
this is a number of pests that have
occurred every day in the UK since 6th
of April up until the the most recent
data which are from yesterday and what
you see is that very dramatic rise that
happened during April so that now we do
have a lot of tests available that allow
us to design the kinds of testing
strategies that we're going to need in
the future next slide please
this is one of the ways we have of
counting how many people in the UK are
infected so in two colors here are
people who have tested positive in dark
blue people who are tested by the NHS
and in orange are people whose tests
were performed by universities research
institutes and private companies so most
of people most of the people in the dark
blue pillars there are either patients
or NHS staff whereas most people in the
orange pillars are other key workers and
this data is extremely interesting but
it is quite susceptible to the fact that
the number of tests has been increasing
and who's allowed to have a test has
also been changing so actually I find
the next slide a lot more informative so
what this is is the number of new in
patients in hospitals in England every
week with Kovic so this is every day
since the 20th of March either in dark
blue an inpatient who was in hospital
and got back a Kobuk positive test
or in gold there somebody who arrived at
hospital having already tested positive
so in so this is always the same kind of
people and these people were always the
top priority to get a test so in some
sense this is a much more pure data
stream than the one I showed you before
and in fact to my mind at least makes
much more sense so what you see is that
number rising from the 20th of March
until it Peaks on the 2nd of April now
the 2nd of April is about the date we
would we would have expected it to peak
because that's about 10 days after the
23rd of March when lockdown came in and
then from the 2nd of April it falls away
pretty rapidly so what this is is the
inflow into the hospital system of
people who are coded positive and we
watch this number with great care every
day if I could have the next slide so if
that was the inflow into the hospital
system this is the total number of
people in hospital with coded on any
given day so that's so that's the bit
really the balance between people who
came in and people who left and so that
has a rather smoother pattern and and a
much slower fall and what you see is
that that peaked around about the 10th
or so of April in London that the peak
in London was much higher than
everywhere else perhaps very slightly
earlier and the fall in the number of
people in hospital in London has been
faster than everywhere else so much so
now actually that in the last couple of
days the number of people in London
sorry in hospital in London now exceeds
numbers in hospital in the Northwest
next slide please
this keeps track of the proportion of
critical care beds that are occupied by
patients with Kobe 19 and what you see
is that that also has fallen from its
peak in early April now down to less
than a third of all the critical care
beds being occupied by Kobe 19 patients
it's been decreasing for most of the UK
over the last two weeks and it's
beginning to come down to what will
might define as more manageable levels
next slide please
these are recorded deaths from Kobe at
19 in blue bars are the actual numbers
reported each day so today being the
fifth of May we got monday's figures in
and you can see there's a very regular
pattern that numbers at the weekend are
always lower than the days subsequently
so that jumped from the 4th of May the
5th of May is something that we would
expect the because this isn't data has
such a strong pattern across different
layers of the week it makes sense to
look at a 7 day rolling average and
that's what the orange line is and what
you can see from that orange line is
that the number of covert recorded
deaths is falling and has been falling
steadily since the middle of April next
slide please
this records registered deaths from Kobe
at 19 by the place where that death
occurred and that we got it for five
different weeks and the most recent week
for which we have this data is is the
week of the 24th of April the gray bars
are deaths in hospital the dark grey
bars are deaths in care homes pale blue
is deaths in one's own home and dark
blue is other places and what you see is
that whilst deaths in hospital have been
falling deaths in care homes in the week
to the 24th of April were still rising
to the extent that
that week deaths in care homes were
about half as many as all the deaths in
hospitals I think what that shows us is
that there is a real issue that we need
to get to grips with about what is
happening in care homes the final slide
for today is a comparison of numbers of
deaths for different countries the UK
which is Cova deaths in all settings is
the gray line in the middle where and
what you see is that deaths in the UK is
still continuing to climb and is higher
than we would wish I think is all I can
say